this is our real thoughts on the wizard
I can't believe I can't believe we
didn't think about doing this one
earlier this was like one of the really
early popular ones I think this came
like right after Batman Robin review and
everyone I think we also hit the perfect
time to review this cuz it was just
coming back in the public eye yeah I
mean honestly I really mean when I say
like you know what we do takes a lot
hard work but I mean like a lot of why
we're so popular it really was good
timing I think we really were just
hitting the height of the popularity of
the whole 80s 90s nostalgia
our generation was hitting that
nostalgic point yeah I think it may not
the hype oh but it was just starting to
happen and like you know james rolfe was
coming in other other people coming and
saying like you know hey let's really
look back and have fun with this and you
know use curt like adult language just
talked about as a doll to make fun of it
it immature but um but yeah so the
wizard the fight thing the fight thing
about it is that when I think back to
this movie it's like I do think bag with
like fun nostalgia but not of watching
the movie more remembering the games of
remembering the clothes and remembering
when video games especially Nintendo was
just everything it was while it really
was when Nintendo roamed fear of it and
I I know there's gonna be some Sega fans
who are you know but it was Nintendo let
it have some great stuff don't get me
wrong I like to demo dissing sake up but
at all it really was like Nintendo there
are some people I had Sega's and there's
a lot of people but a lot of people had
Sega everyone had Nintendo like everyone
did it Shane when Sue when it was super
nintendo versus genesis that got a
little different but early on it was the
NES yeah um and oh god this this movie
just took me back to being like 11 years
old and just salivating at the thought
of Super Mario Brothers 3 the only
reason we saw this movie and noting that
like because at first it was
Oh movie about video games is gonna be
great but it was really that like
glimpse of Super Mario Bros yeah like we
all just like what we saw did they had
the you know the big opening like these
metal doors so - it opens up and which
is only recent only reason we really
wanted to see this movie I mean it is as
cheap a corporate shill as you can get
oh yeah and we bought it hook line &
sinker you know what we fuckin enjoy it
that's because we were idiots
oh no no no holoholo we we did enjoy
what are ye light that we solve Mario 3
but even back then we we do this was a
sad movie patiently through it yes to
get to write we like gentlemen what was
basically just a trailer for Super Mario
Brothers 3 we enjoyed that Nintendo was
popular enough to warn a movie uh vassal
but we did not enjoy the movie
even back then we knew this was this was
at a time when Nintendo was popular
enough to warrant a movie I'm not sure
they are now yeah you may you may be
able to pull something out of a Zelda
maybe a Metroid but not like it was a
badass
um well that they wouldn't be good back
then are you can make them good now you
could oasiz we can get as freakin pixels
yeah we still haven't seen yet but I
don't want to now I want to be revived
I didn't realize it was a heavy Madison
production yeah I didn't either
I once I found out that it was a he's
dad confident like no like I just
thought I just thought it doesn't first
come on they're just so nice Columbus
and some studio in that Adam Sam I
happen to be in it I'm like oh it's a
happy man and protect my you're not like
shit um but yeah it's a so this movie
every kid kind of it was like the Saved
by the Bell of Nintendo movies that that
makes sense this is kind of what we
wanted to be an imagine like we either
were or we're going to become and then
when we look back as adults like yeah
that's not it at all uh we all wanted or
thought we were Lucas uh although nobody
nobody wants w-was sexual
yeah turns out look is all about
speaking I leave noting hipster
including a guy who play Lucas um but
yeah the one thing that like like I
there wasn't what we saw that movie and
they were showing like the power glove
in the case you said everything I love
the power itself but we all kind of
thought like okay it's not doing it
right cuz Lucas is the bat but that's
what they able to make the master
because he was the only one who knew how
to use the power glove nobody else in
the world know how to use that piece of
shit well it's just editing he really
didn't know how to use it well I thank
know but what were your kids are like
huh Marcus he's the only one who knows
how to it fascinates me that Nintendo
between the Wii and all of their little
accessories now are as good as they are
because if you look at their history you
would think that they'd be insane doing
anything that is off-kilter and not
sticking to a console because in those
days all their accessories shocked yeah
oh those days I mean God the couch
avoids the blaster that zapper gun was
about the best yet now school that was
the closest but then we tried like the
bazooka with the super Nintendos like
fuck was that
bazooka the power pad the power glove
fucking Virtual Boy am thick everywhere
bad one durable power pan wasn't bad
yeah until you figured out you could
just cheat by kneeling them yeah and as
you're gonna know just like yeah so yeah
yeah yeah
now terrible um so yeah the the fact
that they became as good as they did
just fascinates me just because what I
like it when I'm watching the power
glove it who plays red racer with the
power yeah no uh so it was one of those
things where it's like you keep the
power club puh-pow your power glove off
that yeah it's like where did that come
hi it's like well I'm a boy or a girl we
just naturally we must hotel food we
amazing common know but we're in we're
in middle school like that it's the
early 130 here yeah like that's it
especially when video games are involved
and stuff but I will say this like she
could play video games that would be the
one thing if I was a kid appealing whoa
hi hi each had the original gamer girl
um that was guys I mean it's like
everyone is always like oh come on
you know girls that when they play games
and they do I really need there were
they were around don't get me wrong they
were they were nearly as many as them
where now I in terms of like gamer girls
back then because I don't we definitely
won't I act them yeah I mean we
definitely do a couple little right
couple but many I were to go through my
school and try to remember you you might
find one girl in a class hmm a series
every big gamer girls do and stuff like
that but it would be they were out there
but not not like it is now it's more
like I don't know um yeah yeah movie is
it's so objective Lee speaking it's not
a good movie no let's get that out of
the way but in a almost in a room kind
of quality it is so strange then it it
least works on just what the fuck am i
watching level there's this one scene
remember it's not what I so many scenes
like this where it's like you almost see
what they're going for but they just
sort of shake your hand what was that
like there's one scene where it's like I
don't know they're just like staying the
night or something like that and he puts
on this supposed to be a creepy
Halloween mask that's not like he hid
and went boo or a gummy then you just
puts it on a tray just goes hey if you
just turn sees it and punches him and
it's just like what happened I think the
whole and the whole is assume in there
somewhere
it's like three separate movies when you
got the video game movie and then
there's the the freakin chase movie
makes no sense
what are you trying to bring back our
kids you fucking monster with a
Christian Slater and the Beau Bridges
yeah yeah like in there yeah and then
this weird wormy guy
I'm gonna bring back those donut dad to
me and I would yeah I was with you I'm
like what how dare you try to bring back
our to and like that was one of my
favorite jokes in the review it kept
cutting - boom bitches right out of that
again the band again Manny Manny maybe
because he was so freakin goofy and then
his Spanky fucking Spanky
the unsub's breasts the unsung hero of
the movie can we all agree that Spanky
saved the day by taking out the little
wormy guy with one of the greatest lines
ever heard you - it's true Chris yeah
man talk about like I said I mean like
the whole the whole creepy like predator
and a file thing back then like it was
definitely there but not as not as scary
in your face but I remember going to go
I was on that yeah like I saw the night
we did over like a bit and then like
nowadays it's like you could never get
away with that where was that then there
what I remember seeing it like we were
11 I was 11 they were you were 9 the
audience reaction was completely split
it was the most hilarious and cuz we
were in the middle of the theater and it
was this reaction of like people
laughing their asses off like when she
goes hey touch my pass like half the
audience went fucking nuts they just
burst out laughing and the other half
their jaws hit the ground just there's
this collective gases whoo
like what the hell and I just remember
my I had both like my job I didn't run
my jaw drop first and then I started
laughing because I'm a people everybody
was like wow yeah how's the opposite
guys laugh I didn't know I think most
children in the audience never thought
to go that route
get out of something like he touched me
in a private area
one I think Milo's the Abbott's house
can't laugh because I knew a funny line
ha way once and then that weird follow a
flyer is my oyster friend she doesn't
even have any brass gets wider fuck - oh
my god here Kenda have any breasts it
doesn't help that he looks kind of has
that creeper well yeah um and they all
turn up AI Delta make a up with Spanky
Spanky good old Spanky surgeon just herb
res I'm like ooh oh this is gonna get
dark like you know like we got a winner
here we gotta use this joke three times
because it's worth the three rule it is
so it is so bizarre that I there's so
many elements of this film that are just
so insane that I enjoyed watching it a
lot when we did the review even though
I'm just like wow this movie is terrible
but I'm having a blast watching it um
the the kid fantasy I think of the power
glove and having this legit
wizard kid you know who's able to use it
and everything and keep he keeps it like
it's nuclear secrets like it's got the
blast codes and you turn a couple keys
and he's gonna blow up Paris or
something like it oh yeah that just add
a bit then the ending the when it
finally finally gets to the Super Mario
Brothers 3 reveal that crazy dude
running the show how everyone the movies
a pedophile
some of them it turns out all but yeah
that's honestly the bet if you think of
it that way the movie is way creepier
but it makes more sense cuz that you've
in particularly is like are you ready my
little kitty she's not the fucking child
care I lit up red and that was it my
brigades he's like the child catcher
from Chitty Chitty Bang Bang I'm like
this hero we have super Maya brothers
three-and-oh free today
this is studio oh my god
it's um it's going to experience and
it's definitely a time capsule uh back
to that time but in terms of like
because this I mean we we drank the
kool-aid I know yeah we did
William my kid had every issue of
Nintendo Power for probably five years
straight we have a subscription we have
the subscription we we always we never
were the first to have the new game on
the block but we always wanted to be the
first I mean we really just had sucker
stamped on our gasps no no we fell for
it uh Bob like I said this week was
eerie no but we at least knew we liked a
little window where we knew the story
was bad and then and I think that boy
that was the disappointing thing about
it was I remember as a kid I'm like I
don't remember like going in to see some
movie about some semi autistic and I
don't know what his deal is like moping
around trying to get to California I was
like I just remember I kept sitting
there going get to the videogames this
isn't What's Eating Gilbert Grape
yeah you know like to play member game
down yeah the opening is nothing but
this kid walking while the credits play
and it's like this is the wizard right
the Nintendo that that was gonna help it
was Super Mario Brothers 3 that's what's
so funny cuz there's a kid I'm just like
what what is this what I I thought it
was going to be all about playing video
games and it's this story about this kid
trying to reconnect then he's got like
he never talks and I I'm like what but
what what what's so interesting too is
that the guy who directed this went on
to do tons of Malcolm's in the Middle's
Malcolm of the Middle's which are like
in my opinion some of the best
interpreters with like childhood
I mean it just Emily the family
environment in general and I thought
it's just one of the most brilliant
shows ever made and it's just like hey
where did that jump happen
I honestly honestly doesn't understand I
know you want Emily or anything now if
you watch the visual design on the
wizard and I automatic said I think if
you watch the actual direction I'm not
so sure it's that the direction is God
although I think the script is tear I
mean come on how are you going to save
something we are acting like kids but
again maybe this part of like the
malcolm milk is like framing this was
like the kid genius and there and i
think if you look at it as if he was
prepping to do malcolm in the middle'
some day that this is him trying to find
his voice you can kind of see it yeah
it's a director trying to find his egg
holder with saddled with a really shitty
script huh um the best thing he had
going for Mazzetti had Fred Savage but I
that's about it but even for a savage I
mean like like I said why he's just
doing his Wonder Years thing like it
just even that's I mean there was
something watching that movie really
Danny I meant what I said the review you
know thank you've really had mad Tana
has mad talent now you know um but it is
one of those things where it's like he
was he did act a little too old he was
just like there's mature kids everything
but then he was like he was a little too
mature it's visually but he was always
like this no no he was and what are
yours for the most part they used it
okay sometimes they went overboard but
in this one I was just really seeing
like he does not act like a kid I don't
even Princess Bride why do you again
like grandpa no it's okay sit down like
what you don't get you don't talk like
you don't feel Frankie Muniz though like
does them no no but he has an excuse
that he's a child genius and even really
that whole family like I said they
worked it in the same way Wonder Years
did because they can't help to
orchestrate a trek across California you
don't think he's a child please they
never explained how or why those he had
a way out actually
more believe that the kid that's good at
video games orchestrated back because he
does have served like there's one side
of the mind that's like a genius gathers
everything is going according to put but
I won't believe it on to the girl it's
like sort of like you know they all talk
like they're players in Vegas or
something like e1 yeah or even like just
the hey you know you got a train ticket
get a cash in it I mean if I never talk
like you know like kids ah I guess I see
I think probably he was going for that
say malcolm in the middle' tone I just
didn't come off right uh I think that
I'm not sure there's a but I think this
may be part of the problem I'm not sure
this director was trying to portray real
kids cuz if you okay like Lucas what
kids really like Lucas I met that team
of disciples around him like this is
over-the-top
he's like video game Jesus yeah um so I
I think it was meant to be over the top
and I think maybe this director being
fresh and a little green at the moment
like didn't know quite how to pull it
off I mean by malcolm in the middle' i
think he nailed it because you can tell
that is pure fantasy but also really
funny but it also has some family drama
and like it's got every day i think
that's probably what he wanted to go for
the wizard but between the shitty script
he may not have quite had a my all about
mm no now you have to push this now push
this now point should i be sure the
studio or whatever it is like it is like
the Marvel movie of its day it's like
but I want to tell the story about this
kid trying to reconnect with the
childhood that he lost because it's been
now there are mothers right ya know but
to put a trailer for The Avengers in
there um so I don't know but if I feel
like I feel like somewhere there's an
interesting movie winding it up I feel
like if it was more about the the kids
fantasy part of it it would have been
better
um yeah strange way like making an I
feel real family drama and stuff like
that just it's yeah well you can tell
the heart is there I mean like you
even going to like the dinosaurs at the
end of point the lunch found like it's
like he's got the right like sort of
feel it's just it's an ischemic knows
that it's just something no kid in for
that movie that type of movie wanted to
see yeah it would be like going into
like a GI Joe movie and getting a
heartfelt story about cancer it's like
you know you can be like well I'm just
trying my best to tell a story that any
meaning but what what child really
wanted to see that it was in the same
sort of kinds of it's like this could
have actually been a decent movie if you
took Nintendo out of Nvidia video games
were how this kid basically got you know
was able to express himself that's fine
but the fact that it's a Nintendo
commercial doesn't help um but like I
could see how the work but but not in
this film is it's like it's the tones
not right yeah if it was more like
Malcolm you know words just like this
kids fantasy and some moments are like
they're clearly not in our universe
that's for goddamn sure and that's kind
of what saves this movie and makes it so
hilarious as you're just watching these
moments and you're like what fuckin I am
ready adults y'all like met the
businessmen playing like whatever fuckin
Donkey Kong or something like that it's
like get up I bet you my kid brother
over there can be like a hunch I'm good
at a child's game Shelly you jest
it's just wheeled in a dumbass world we
were way past that point words I know
now no the children can kick your ass
like I get that probably would have
played better more and what especially
if anyone's gonna be good enough reason
I'm in the shoot that's clearly like a
lawyer like an EDS lawyer or something
like that
man what if that would have worked
better if it were the early 80s and mid
eighties where it still was everybody
playing video like in the early days you
would see you would see like people who
are already teenagers playing these and
they would still be playing it I was
like in is 50 no that's what that's what
bothered me I'm like this does not work
right with his age in this timeframe I
mean this would see would have worked
better ten years earlier um should say
ten years there's only 91 but you know
like six years five years earlier I
don't know but yeah it's clearly in its
own wacky wacky world so yeah it's it's
a movie that like if people are still
talking about now it's a very obvious
corporate sellout film that tried to
have elements of drama but clearly
disarming or corpus yeah I mean again
it's very much like our you know it is
like whatever probably you're we're
watching it's like your generation High
School Musical or something like that
right say yeah you know it's dumb now
but it was your dump you know it's like
that was our dumb that was our like
fantasy that we realize now it's really
really stupid they even think that we
can do it was stupid but we like that
Nintendo still so insane I think some of
our does it just hold up and what the
hell with it ya know it's just so
interesting in so many of these choices
they make and how much you could not get
away with so many these choices now so
yeah it's like it's entertaining um it's
uh how do I foot it's even kind of
entertaining in its boredom even the
boring scenes are just so pulls their
their mouths yeah they're mesmerizing in
how strange they are it's yeah it's just
it's like looking at a puzzle you you
just watching like what what were they
thinking if I could get into their mind
how can easy answers go together I don't
get it hey but uh who doesn't talk
videogames Fred Savage Spanky touch my
breasts I know how did these things I've
got old man and green speedo oh yeah old
man greens me though beau bridges
Christian Slater what wardrobe was like
okay we're giving cash is everybody that
you see the old man throw that on
hi why so much why too much why you go
around um but and I still I I did love
Ebert's commentary way back in the day
about like I barely even play video
games and I know that these things are
edited right how'd you go from level 1
to level 5 in a minute yeah that's
really sense
I played Ninja Turtles I know that you
do not go although I'm watching it again
I I think he might have met you again
that wrong cuz I thought that too when I
was a kid but watching it again he says
you're still playing that game he says
yeah I got to the mecha turtle and blah
blah blah the last time I play I know I
think sanitized ya know but but it's
like that's why I thought it hurts too
because I felt like wait a bit no that's
not the law that's not the love but they
said last time so I think you've heard
Nick Lee birth God rest his soul
laughs I totally buy that I would call
bullshit on that he doesn't seem like
the type who ever played teenage with
Ninja Turtles not addressing what up I'm
checking on the Konami version the
original one that was damn near
impossible
I will say this like he said these I am
what do I know about video games don't
they by dunno I got to level three
yeah Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
battling the mecha turtle so when he
says I'm like no you didn't unless you
really devoted time to this you did not
get to level three unless you hate kids
helper you were just watching see that's
the thing I think he was babysitting
some nephews or somebody and like yeah
like I I have a heart I am a hard time
swallowing man no no like another game I
have having new to Turtles and I love
you Roger you you're up there oh no you
had help you were out I'm not sure I'm
not sure I buy it now watcher is calling
a dead man hi when you seen him I'm
having trouble swallowing that one I
have doubt oh but uh ya know it is what
it is it's the wizard it is cold Stan oh
it's still one of my favorite reviews
that we did it's uh just run Lucas alone
one of my favorite is you just Lukas
taunting yeah some point like we just
had like something call Mike he's
reading a magazine just in the movie
just turns his head like a super bill he
doesn't yeah we gave him like his own
sound - yeah it's great so um yeah
amazing movie uh probably not for the
reasons if you movies are amazing if you
want to know what am I like reasons you
want to know it was like growing up the
late 80s or we night and what we thought
it was like I thought it was like it is
it is one of the best time capsule
movies you can watch because when I
think of about FM come I was in 1990
like 89 or 91 it was right it was right
crossing somewhere into the new decade
when I think about that time I
automatically think of the wizard so
just yeah great time capsule if you want
to know what made us the weirdos we are
today that's the heavy so that's Bobby
we'll see you the next one later